monsieur le premier ministre nous avons
un problème
le nombre de morts à la guerre explose
le plancher nous craignons une
disparition totale de la population
si je dis j'ai une idée
on va passer une loi pour interdire la
mort à la guerre ok premières mesures du
gouvernement pour résorber la mort à la
guerre
faire semblant pour nous comprendre la
situation regardons ensemble le sujet de
gibles seychelles depuis la mise en
vigueur de cette loi le visage de la
guerre a bien changé hier on pouvait
voir des champs de bataille rempli le
sens de membres arrachés ou encore de
bishr à même le sol
aujourd'hui tout cela n'est qu'un
lointain souvenir toi même la torture
prend une meilleure tournure a passé un
cap cette liste de chiens jamais genton
jallet ici maintenant qu'est-ce qui
tâche
c'est la boue non ce relou c'est relou
j'en ai marre ça va wave est mort
monsieur le premier ministre nous avons
encore un problème comme les gens ne
meurent plus à la guerre nous
connaissons une hausse démographique
sans précédent
j'ai une idée on va enterrer nos morts
pour de fonds pour de vrai hockey
ok je suis pas vraiment décédé j'y peux
rien c'est les ordres je ne suis pas
mort en fait
pas bien